you're part of the extreme microbiome
project
what does that evolve and what kind of
fun
fun organisms
have you learned about have you gotten
to explore we have a really fun project
xmp the extreme microbiome which is as
it sounds like we look for really odd
places like
heavy radiation environments high salt
high or low temperature you know strange
area the space station for example lots
of radiation in microgravity places
where organisms can evolve for
interesting adaptations and some of them
have been organisms we've seen like a
candy pink lake in australia called lake
hillier which would just publish a paper
on this word why is it pink uh so it's
actually uh denelia salinas these one of
these organisms there's a mixture of
bacteria
and some algae that are there that make
it bright pink so they actually make
carotenoids these like really sort of uh
orangey and kind of pink molecules when
you look at them in the light so if you
know if you get enough of the bacteria
it becomes pink so it's not just pink
it's like a bubble gum pink the lake and
so we uh that that's just an odd it's a
halophile being said it grows in 30 salt
and if you go below 10 15 percent salt
it doesn't even grow it actually kills
it
yeah there it is liqueur is it toxic to
humans or no it so when you walk in the
pink lake actually it's so hypertonic
meaning it's so salty you can feel it
lysing and killing your cells on your
foot so it actually hurts to walking
because it's so salty
uh so yeah so but it won't kill you
listen you have to suffer for art that's
right great art requires software i mean
so it is a beautiful lake uh you have to
get permits to go sample there but we
actually just got an email last week
there's pilots who fly over this in
australia because they love the color
yeah so he emailed us one of the pilots
and he said hey guys i saw you publish
his paper
it's not as pink as it used to be
because he loves flying over it and it
was like a little bit less pink because
i had a bunch of rain in the past few
weeks so it was just a little bit
diluted so we reassured him it'll get
more pink as they grow again uh but
basically yeah it's a beautiful pink
lake and so that is gorgeous
it's almost like it's like a dr seuss
book or something it's like it doesn't
even look hard to get to yeah there's no
road you have to basically fly uh land
nearby and then paddle in but so it's
not next to anything
so it's hard to get to but once you get
there it's beautiful if anyone knows how
to get there let me know i want to go
there